So far all of the types of used are built into Python. If we wanted to find new
ways of working with data and they'll find new operations, we need to define our
own types. That's what we'll learn next and the way to define your own type in
Python is to make a class. let's recap what we were doing with our web search
engine. We have the crawler module and the crawl.web procedures that would
output two objects, that record that everything that we've learned from a web
crawl. The first is the index, that's the mapping between keywords and the list
of URLs that appear and we use dict, object to record that. And the second was
the dictionary object that maps URLs to ranks. This is what we used to record
the pageranks and then we need to keep track of both of those objects, pass them
into lucky-search in the right way to get the right output. What we'd like to do
by defining our own type is to encapsulate all this into one object. So, one of
the key things that defining our own types gives us it's called encapsulation.
And encapsulation means we can group many things into one object, provide a nice
clean interface, so the only thing the crawler needs to produce is this one
object. And that's the only thing search needs to work on. And so, our goal is
to create a new module, and by using encapsulation instead of having to deal
with all that complexity. We'll have one output which is a WebCorpus output and
that's what's used in search. And, by using Abstraction, we'll hide all the
details of how the internals of the WebCorpus are represented. All search needs
to understand is how to use it to respond to queries.